When you arrive at the dentist's office,...
...you will probably sit down for a few minutes in a waiting room.
There may be paperwork for you to sign.
When it is time for your exam,...
...a person called a dental hygienist will bring you to a special exam room.
A dental hygienist is the person who cleans your teeth.
You'll be asked to sit down in a special chair.
The hygienist will also have you wear a bib.
The bib will keep you clean in the event that toothpaste or other materials...
...accidentally drop on you during your visit.
If you have teeth that hurt, you should tell the dental hygienist.
If your teeth hurt when you eat or drink, let them know.
The hygienist will wear a mask on their face and gloves on their hands...
...to prevent the spread of germs.
During your exam, the hygienist will slowly look throughout your mouth...
...and at each of your teeth.
It will be necessary for them to use a small mirror...
...to look at areas of your mouth that are difficult to see.